[Música]
duelo de Titanes en las redes sociales
la compañía de Mark Zuckerberg meta
lanzó una nueva aplicación
twits le compite de frente a Twitter del
multimillonario y los Mask Aunque tienen
una interfaz similar y se ven muy
parecidas hay varios puntos que no
tienen en común por ejemplo freaks no
permite los mensajes directos con el
argumento de mantener la conversación
pública y tampoco tiene opción de
guardar borradores de mensajes ni usa
hashtags como si ocurre en Twitter sin
embargo freaks permite hasta 500
caracteres por publicación esto es casi
el doble de los 280 de Twitter y Su
contenido multimedia puede durar hasta 5
minutos mientras que en la app de elon
musk sólo van hasta 2 minutos 28
segundos por último freuds es más
riguroso con la seguridad virtual por un
lado si exige la verificación de los
datos personales para abrir una cuenta y
tiene unas políticas de privacidad más
estrictas que son iguales a las de
Instagram y Facebook y muy indistintas a
las de Twitter donde se permiten por
ejemplo los insultos y los desnudos
Twitter ya entabló una demanda contra
streets por supuestamente haberse
apropiado de su conocimiento contratando
empleados que la compañía iniciada la
había despedido pero más allá de las
disputas Cuál es la causa realmente son
tan parecidas estas aplicaciones y
lograrás construir una conversación
pública como quiere hoy en el debate
estamos en nuestro estudio con Karen
rosso periodista de tecnología y editora
jefe de publimetro Colombia y desde
Córdoba Argentina nos acompaña Javier
fallero activista y analista de
políticas digitales a ustedes dos
bienvenidos y a quienes nos escuchan y
nos ven los invito a que dejen sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales con el hashtag el debate f24
estamos en Twitter y en streets por
supuesto y también en Facebook e
Instagram como arroba
franz24 raya el piso es y a mí me
encuentran como arroba María claguirre
además pueden escuchar nuestro podcast a
través de Apple podcast Spotify deezer y
TuneIn
Karen bienvenida a nuestros estudios
aquí en Bogotá Gracias por acompañarnos
Comencemos con la pregunta que todo se
hacen realmente son tan parecidas y
Twitter y esta primera podría quitarle
público a la compañía de elon musk Bueno
yo creo que hay que partir de tener en
cuenta que lo que ha logrado traeds
durante esta desde su lanzamiento hasta
el día de hoy no se Iguala lo que ha
hecho Twitter desde su lanzamiento Y eso
de entrada ya nos pone en el radar algo
que puede estar ocurriendo y la
conversación que se viene sobre el tema
pero la preocupación más grande de esto
es qué tan abierta va a ser porque
Facebook o meta tiene políticas claras
sobre qué se puede hablar cómo se puede
hablar que se puede publicar y esto yo
creo que es realmente lo que genera el
debate y la diferencia entre las dos
pero es cierto también que la base con
la que parte streets tiene interacción
de Facebook e interacción de Instagram y
esto es bastante atractivo para los
anunciantes que ya han visto resultados
en por ejemplo sus campañas a través de
Instagram que como la cuna base de lo
que es hoy en día 3 entonces podría ser
como también hay quienes analizan o
dicen que podría ser el siguiente paso
de Instagram pero más allá del tema yo
creo que realmente el como digamos que
el foco lo que hay que tener clave Aquí
es hasta qué punto si permite opinar o
va a dejar opinar porque pues no podemos
quedarnos solamente con que Instagram
por ejemplo es una red social que
históricamente ha sido bastante
criticada por los daños que hace a la
salud mental de los jóvenes entonces va
a ser este Dos punto cero a nivel de
opinión Entonces qué va a pasar con el
concepto de realidad y con lo que
realmente ocurre o sea Hasta dónde vamos
a poder hablar digamos de escenarios
políticos de escenarios nacionales Como
por ejemplo en el caso de Colombia que
todo el tiempo está circulando noticias
y videos de denuncias vamos a tener
censura no vamos a tener censura esa es
Realmente es como la diferencia entre la
una y la otra usted apunta sin duda los
temas centrales de este debate pero
quiero comenzar con ese éxito Con ese
comienzo exitoso deathers y para ello
quiero darle la bienvenida a Javier
Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en France
24 Le quiero preguntar cómo entender una
cifra que se ha dicho bastante Y es que
en tan solo cinco días ha alcanzado los
100 millones de usuarios y que esta es
el lanzamiento más exitoso para
cualquier red social incluso más exitoso
que el del chat
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
y creo que el éxito se debe bastante a
lo que la compañera recién estaba
explicando a esta cuestión de que
Twitter ha cambiado Twitter con sus
reglas demasiado laxas con el aumento de
cuentas
inauténticas por así decir con una
relajación de los términos de uso y de
moderación de contenidos que hacen que
el discurso tóxico haya aumentado mucho
últimamente desde que elon musk que está
en la red han generado una necesidad de
una alternativa a Twitter hay muchísima
gente que ya no ve en Twitter aquella
red Donde había líderes de opinión que
estaban verificados y que tenía una
cierta curación de contenidos para hacer
un un lugar en donde uno fuera a buscar
información ahora está un poco más
desordenada la cuestión Entonces eso
genera la necesidad de una alternativa
hay algunas por ejemplo de código
abierto como mastodon o Blue Sky pero
esta alternativa que está presentando la
empresa de Mark Zuckerberg meta tiene
esta ventaja justamente que se marcaba
recién de estar vinculada con Instagram
y por lo tanto ya tiene una mínima red
contención un grafo social de amigos con
el cual uno ya entra y tiene con quién
hablar no a veces en las alternativas no
hay mucha gente que uno conozca en este
caso Sí por eso creo yo que se da esta
este crecimiento por una necesidad muy
particular de un discurso público
ustedes dos están apuntando un poco al
discurso de soccer verk que es vamos a
crear un lugar para tener una
conversación pública y una conversación
segura y de hecho usted Javier habla de
evitar un discurso tóxico que se ve en
Twitter sin embargo también suckerberg y
los creadores de streets están
asegurando que ellos no pretenden
reemplazar a Twitter sino que el público
al que se van a ir dirigidos a los
tuiteros que estén cansados de esta red
social y a las personas de Instagram que
quieren tener una conversación mucho más
fluida realmente puede ser fruits un
reemplazo de Twitter o quizás la
siguiente versión y realmente qué tantos
esta conversación sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta las imposiciones o restricciones
que pone al lenguaje Javier
Bueno yo creo que puede llegar a ser en
algunos casos para la mayoría de las
personas un reemplazo pero en otros un
complemento no tiene que haber en el
debate público en línea distintos tipos
de espacios nosotros cuando estamos en
la vida real por así decir aunque la
vida en línea también la vida real
tenemos distintos espacios en la iglesia
Hablamos de ciertas cosas con un grupo
de Amigos íntimos hablamos de otras con
la familia y con los compañeros de
trabajo hablamos de otras entonces en
las redes necesitamos distintos tipos de
espacios con mayores y menores rangos de
tolerancia en el discurso si muchos
discursos valiosos políticamente
públicamente como el de las protestas
por ejemplo que se mencionaba recién es
suele estar en los límites de las reglas
de uso de las plataformas por eso está
bueno que existan distintas plataformas
con distintas reglas de uso entonces me
parece que este va a ser un complemento
y hay una sola cosa más para destacar
que es que esta nueva red que está
creando meta freds está hecha sobre un
protocolo técnico que permite la
interoperabilidad con redes abiertas
como más todo entonces la gente va a
poder hablar entre distintos servidores
con distintas reglas sobre distintos
temas más adelante quiero volver con
usted para que nos explique un poco más
Cómo funcionaría esta interoperabilidad
pero quiero regresar con usted Karen y
preguntarle digamos que del lado de las
personas que respaldan Twitter hay una
críticas diciendo que va a restringir la
libertad de expresión usted está de
acuerdo Pues es que tenemos que ver que
históricamente todo el universo de meta
ha tenido una fuerte crítica sobre que
digamos que son pocos creadores
generando contenido para mucha gente que
ve mientras que Twitter era una red
social que permitía que cualquier
persona pudiera expresar su opinión y
ese era el verdadero atractivo de
Twitter Hasta cierto punto obvio con los
cambios que ha tenido y que venían
mencionando Aquí también nuestro colega
Pues digamos que eso empezó a sesgarse
un poco pero al final del día terminaba
haciendo una red social en la que
cualquier persona tiempo y expresar su
pensamiento estuviera bien o no igual
digamos que el tema era que se podía
expresar Entonces cuando nosotros
empezamos a tener políticas claras como
las que tiene metas sobre Qué
información vamos a publicar y cómo lo
vamos a hacer Pues en cierto modo si
estamos limitados pero al final de
cuentas como usuarios sabemos que el
aceptar términos y condiciones Pues nos
está llevando precisamente a tener esta
conversación de que puedo y que no puedo
hacer en ciertas plataformas no entonces
esa es la otra La otra cara del debate y
de hasta donde digamos que sí podría
tener una ser un reemplazo o no serlo Y
cómo meta llega a ser el ejemplo de por
decirlo así de la restricción y la
moderación del lenguaje después de todos
los escándalos que atravesó Mark
Zuckerberg de vender los datos de los
usuarios a diferentes empresas Pues es
que precisamente cuando sale todo el
tema de Cambridge analítica empieza a
haber un cambio dentro de la compañía
porque ya hay una responsabilidad social
y una responsabilidad sobre Hasta qué
punto nosotros estamos generando
que se lleven a cabo estas decisiones
políticas por ejemplo como fue en el
caso de Estados Unidos y hoy en día Pues
si nosotros trasladamos eso a eso
digamos a países como por ejemplo en el
caso de Colombia donde la educación a
veces puede ser un poco más limitada
pues empiezan a jugar estas estas redes
sociales como una de las plataformas
digamos de información masiva entonces
por eso es tan importante digamos cuando
en Twitter un político puede compartir
algo pero también viene el juego de Yo
solo veo lo que a mí me interesa Y lo
que a mí me gusta y no veo la otra
postura Entonces ahí es donde empieza
todo el tema de responsabilidad social
que sí Es evidente que las plataformas
lo tienen que tener y que es necesario
que como usuarios también tengamos en
cuenta eso Pues hasta qué punto yo
consumo esto que me gusta pero entiendo
la realidad del otro y cómo lo respeto y
cómo lo comparto a través de mis redes
sociales para no seguir alimentando un
discurso que ya sabemos que nos ha
llevado a decisiones Pues digamos en el
ámbito político de un sector o de otro
Javier y cómo se puede llevar esta
conversación entre múltiples operadores
más
Bueno tal como lo mencionaba recién ahí
Karen cada red social o cada gran
empresa intermediaria de comunicaciones
pone unas reglas Sí y Esas reglas suelen
ser monolíticas suelen ser la misma
regla para todo el mundo para todo
público Sí en distintas situaciones si
uno quiere crear un espacio que sea apto
para todo público y que sea ecuménico
donde todo el mundo pueda venir a
expresarse usualmente tiene que poner
unas reglas muy estrictas sí que a veces
van a limitar la libertad de expresión
sí y que no van a tener mucho el lugar
para detalles regionales idiomáticos Sí
y cuestiones que son muy importantes a
tener en cuenta entonces mientras que
más amplios el público más restringido a
veces es el debate en esa plaza pública
privada no
con los servidores
interoperables Y federados eso va
cambiando uno puede tener un servidor de
personas que se dedican a hablar más de
ciertos temas que de otros con sus
propias reglas que distintas a las de
streets ahora en los aspectos en donde
Esas reglas sean compatibles o los
servidores que tengan reglas parecidas
van a poder siempre bajo elección de
ellos mismos hablar entre sí sí entre
distintos servidores para que gente que
no está en meta en tres porque por
ejemplo no le gusta la política
extractivista de datos personales que
tiene puede quedarse en un servidor
diferente Pero siempre y cuando las
reglas sean parecidas van a poder
hablarse con usuarios de estrés es como
en el email uno puede tener un email en
gmail o puede tenerlo en Hotmail en
Yahoo o en un servidor en su casa Sí el
protocolo es el mismo los emails se
hablan entre sí uno puede mandar samaels
entre distintas empresas Sí esta idea es
parecida distintas empresas distintas
bases técnicas para poder hablarse entre
sí siempre y cuando las reglas de uso
sean compatibles ustedes nos habla
Javier de cómo poder utilizar un factor
común o las redes sociales que tienen un
factor común las personas y los usuarios
las pueden utilizar sin también hay un
antepasado Y es que en la historia de
las empresas le está sirviendo de
respaldo a los creadores de streets para
no repetir los mismos errores y
recordemos que meta es la compañía dueña
de Facebook Instagram WhatsApp y ahora
freds y al respecto el jefe de Instagram
como bien lo decía usted Karen la red
social de la cual se nutre porque
normalmente trae parte de los usuarios
que tenemos en en instagram Adam moser
decía en el medio de birch y esto lo
cito textualmente fuimos demasiado
rápidos en prometerle demasiado a la
industria con Facebook a principios de
2010 y sería un error repetir eso Karen
Cuál es el error que no puede repetir de
Facebook
pues es que es un tema bastante complejo
porque desde digamos desde
la parte neta de lo que son las redes
sociales son diferentes porque tu red
social en Facebook lo que hacías era
buscar amigos y en esta estás expresando
tus ideas creo que realmente aquí el
tema es que el abrir la brecha a poder
permitir a las personas comunicar
estaría llevando también a que hay una
responsabilidad de que Facebook no
podría o meta no podría limitar
diferentes posturas políticas porque
evidentemente se va a volver un
escenario político O sea ya tenemos
políticos ahí por más de que moser y
diga no nuestro interés no es ser
político ni tampoco difundir noticias
porque hasta cierto punto pues la
conversación no puede ser solo como
amaneciste hoy sino la conversación es
qué es lo que está pasando en nuestro
entorno entonces precisamente el el
error que no podría cometer es caer en
eso de mostrar lo que la gente solo
quiere ver desde un punto de la Baraja y
no ser equiparable en los dos en los dos
puntos de vista Javier retomo algo que
está diciendo Karen y que también es el
núcleo de suetes y ellos están diciendo
no queremos tener una conversación
política y palabras más palabras menos
han dicho esto requiere unas unos
riesgos en medidas de restricciones de
libertad de expresión de libertad
política etcétera que no están
balanceados con con lo que obtiene la
empresa entonces Ellos están diciendo no
A diferencia de Twitter no será un
espacio político Pero cómo hablar
entonces de una conversación pública
excluyendo lo que ellos llaman las hard
news o las noticias duras y la política
Bueno eso es realmente Una un ejercicio
de pensamiento mágico por parte de Adam
moscer y el el ceo de Instagram es
imposible hacer que la gente no hable de
política aunque no hable de política
partidaria o Aunque el algoritmo de
recomendación de contenidos no
privilegia las noticias la gente va a
seguir compartiendo noticias y va a
seguir hablando de cuestiones políticas
eso es inevitable lo que sí debería
hacer en este caso Instagram aprendiendo
de la experiencia de Facebook es ser más
transparente respecto de cómo modera
contenidos qué cosas permite Qué cosas
no permite más transparentes sobre cómo
recomienda algorítmicamente contenidos
algo que tampoco se hizo antes y ser más
cuidadoso con la protección de los datos
personales sí que es algo también que es
una una de las grandes deudas que
siempre tuvo Facebook Aunque hoy en día
ha avanzado muchísimo en cuanto a lo que
es el cumplimiento de normativas
importantes como el reglamento europeo
de protección de datos personales que
puso una gran vara sobre la cual muchas
empresas ahora están empezando a
adaptarse y que termina beneficiándonos
a todos pero creo que esos son los
cambios principales que tendría que
hacer para tener en cuenta
este esta nueva dimensión con esta nueva
red que están abriendo y Qué tan lejos
está de ser un poco más rigurosos con la
privacidad de los datos de los usuarios
teniendo en cuenta que en este momento
en la Unión Europea no existe
precisamente por esas políticas que
usted nos nombra
creo que una de las cosas que van a
tener que hacer como hicieron antes con
whatsapp es adaptar los términos de uso
para los usuarios europeos hay cierto
tipo de prácticas internas de la empresa
de compartición de datos personales
entre unas aplicaciones y otras dentro
de la misma empresa que son aceptables
en Estados Unidos por ejemplo pero que
en Europa no entonces de manera similar
a lo que le pasó con WhatsApp antes
cuando fue cuando adquirieron WhatsApp
van a tener que adaptar Esas reglas
pedir consentimiento especial y
específico para los usuarios de Europa y
hacer algunos ajustes técnicos por
ejemplo de donde se localizan los datos
Y cómo se acceden para poder abrir el
servicio en Europa pero creo que lo van
a poder adaptar fácilmente es una
cuestión más bien de cumplimiento
contractual tal como hicieron con
WhatsApp y van a poder abrirlo en Europa
sin problema Karen usted mencionaba algo
y es en la práctica ya están utilizando
freuds para propósitos políticos y
además tengamos en cuenta que es la
competencia sobre todo twitters
localizado en Estados Unidos que ya va
de Cara a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2024
Cómo hacer o si estas dos redes sociales
pueden jugar algún papel en esa campaña
presidencial teniendo en cuenta que
desde que elon musk es el ceo de Twitter
esta red social se volvió más de derecha
Pues es que yo creo que ahí el el punto
clave es que son públicos diferentes
Twitter en Twitter Tú encuentras gente
que lleva diez años 11 años 12 años
dentro de la red social y traeds
obviamente sí tenemos gente diferentes
edades pero el atractivo es el Nicho
juvenil porque viene del público de
Instagram Entonces lo hace atractivo eso
y yo creo que ahí es donde podemos
empezar a jugar digamos desde estrategia
política A qué público quiero llegar
cómo le voy a hablar porque la
conversación es diferente Ya sé que
entres puedo decir hola Buenos días
mientras que en Twitter puedo mostrar un
vídeo de denuncia Entonces ese tipo de
conversación va a ser que sea mucho más
digamos que fácil para un político poder
segmentar públicos de cierta de cierta
manera Aunque todavía no tenemos muy
claro Cómo funciona el algoritmo de
trets que es lo que hablábamos de
transparencia Y entonces Hasta qué punto
podremos utilizar esto la estrategia
para llegarle más al usuario Lo que sí
es cierto es que con todas estas
políticas digamos que la personalización
o el saber a qué tipo de público le va a
llegar va a ser mucho más efectiva
porque tengo su perfil de Instagram
tengo su perfil de WhatsApp Estoy
compartiendo su información en twits
tengo también los permisos que me dio
entonces claro por eso les digo que a
final de cuentas de Cara a los
anunciantes anunciantes no solo
compañías sino en este caso políticos
pues es bastante atractiva La Apuesta
porque termina siendo casi que un todo
en uno en una sola compañía y eso es lo
que es interesante y lo que está detrás
de la conversación pero entonces de cara
al público Sí sería una conversación
transparente en el sentido que se
prohíben de hecho los mensajes directos
para evitar que esa conversación sea
privada sino que siempre se hable
públicamente pero tras bambalinas el que
pierdes el usuario no porque sus datos
ya no los tiene solo Instagram O
WhatsApp sino ya toda esta cadena de
aplicaciones de meta claro y
precisamente por eso es que atendiendo
digamos a todo lo que en un principio
hablábamos de Cambridge se creó como en
Facebook un espacio de transparencia de
anunciantes para saber quién pagaba Por
qué campaña de qué y ahí es cuando Pues
digamos que ahorita también entra lo que
está pasando con reds y es hasta qué
punto Pues el acceso a información que
se está dando Porque algo tan digamos
que puede ser bobo que es no poder
borrar la cuenta de tretsing eliminar la
cuenta de Instagram automática me está
ligando a seguir dando mi información
entonces esto digamos que es lo que hace
que al final de cuentas pues se alimente
todo ese metaverso futuro que tiene que
tiene en la cabeza Soccer
personificar A quién está acá
físicamente Ese es su sueño y
evidentemente hoy en día le estamos
haciendo la tarea mucho más fácil con el
tema de aceptar y dar nuestra
información mucho más fácil y siendo así
Javier no sería paradójico o
contradictorio por decirlo más
directamente que se digan una
conversación más transparente Pero y
fuera de la política pero detrás están
construyendo todo esta meta Data que
puede servir para las campañas políticas
Sí yo no veo la contradicción de todas
maneras porque son dimensiones
diferentes no por un lado espacios como
estos son grandes habilitadores del
debate público pero por el otro son
empresas concentradas tan y como ustedes
decían que tienen grandes capacidades de
analizar conductas y de tratar también
de vender anuncios Sí y torcer el debate
público para unos lugares o para otros
sí aunque yo soy un escéptico de los
efectos
digamos que se dice que tienen algunas
de esas campañas de manipulación pero de
todas maneras son grandes jugadores muy
poderosos que limitan el debate público
también si quisieran entonces creo que
son distintas dimensiones que van
jugando como un juego de pesos y
contrapesos está el elemento de la
privacidad que como recién explicaban es
muy complicado y que le da una ventaja
competitiva enorme a meta está esta
posibilidad también de hacer anuncios
muy dirigidos a ciertos grupos de
personas Lo Que Tiene ciertas
consecuencias también incluidas las del
debate público pero también están los
elementos habilitantes del debate lugar
en donde se puede conversar sobre
política donde se puede tener también
una capacidad crítica organizar
movimientos sociales etcétera no
entonces las redes sociales y esta no
escapa de eso tienen múltiples
dimensiones entonces hay cosas que son
poco contradictorias pero que también
son complementarias Por eso hay que
analizarlas por separado e ir apuntando
y hacia regulaciones y hacia
alternativas como las de las tecnologías
federadas que mencionaba recién que nos
vayan dando nosotros el tipo de
experiencia que querramos tener lo más
importante es tener opciones justamente
y es lo que usualmente no tenemos hoy en
día en estos mercados tan concentrados
y frente a esas opciones Javier Cuál es
el panorama que que queda con Twitter y
trates y cuál es el balance que hace
usted sobre todo en esta lucha entre
Soccer y musk
creo que esto nos da una especie de
ventanita a lo que pasaría cuando hay
opciones le se le ha dado ahora al menos
de una manera más pública sencilla y
directa una opción a la gente y la gente
saltó hacia la opción hay que ver
después Qué pasa este crecimiento
meteórico hay que ver Después qué pasa
con la permanencia esto es muy común en
las nueve redes Por lo general suele
haber una gran alza en nuevas cuentas
pero después la gente no las utiliza
tanto en el tiempo sabrá tener qué pasa
con eso pero me parece que se viene una
época en la que se empiezan a discutir
más las consecuencias de Esto justamente
otra gran pregunta que surge aquí es Qué
pasó con Twitter porque justamente
cambió el dueño de una gran empresa y de
repente una enorme plataforma global de
conversación pública hizo así y cambió
sus reglas y sus consecuencias no
entonces
este tipo de debates me parece son muy
interesantes Qué pasa cuando se
concentra El Poder y justamente a través
de esto vamos a empezar a ver opciones
que tenemos y más cosas que vamos a
poder hacer en el futuro esperemos con
estas redes federadas y también con
regulación no en Europa se está
regulando también mucho el tema de
competencia y a través de la digital
Markets act se está empezando a ver
también el tema del dominio que muchas
de estas empresas tienen en distintas
áreas de la economía digital y frente a
esta multiplicidad de opciones Qué papel
entra Karen a jugar tiktok en esta
batalla Aunque digamos es una aplicación
totalmente diferente Pero si representa
o no también una alternativa distinta
Para quienes no quieran ni Twitter ni
ninguna de las aplicaciones de meta sino
que se vayan por tiktok Yo creo que
históricamente el atractivo de tiktok ha
sido precisamente hacer eso ofrecer algo
totalmente diferente a lo que conocíamos
en su momento cuando llega
revolucionando el tema de contenido
rápido y de vídeo que te cuenta todo en
30 segundos eso atrapa atrapa las nuevas
generaciones y atrapa nuevas tendencias
y ahí es cuando empieza a ser
interesante porque Claro ya en el menú
tengo diferentes ofertas tengo la red
social de fotos pero ahora tengo la red
social de video pero también tengo la
red social de opinión y precisamente
como decía nuestro colega Pues es
interesante tener estas ofertas y hoy en
día con las nuevas generaciones y con
ese consumo rápido de contenido pues
termina siendo sumamente atractivo el
poder manejar estrategias o poder
incluso volverme un creador de contenido
interesante que no se aprendí a hacer
algo en mi casa y quiero contarlo que
básicamente era volviendo a poder dar a
conocer o poder digamos abrir Estos
espacios para que cualquier persona haga
contenido pues termina siendo sumamente
atractivo y por eso es que yo creo que
tiktok digamos que en saliéndose un poco
de toda esa pelea y ese debate porque no
tiene mucho que ver ahí directamente si
está siendo un punto clave dentro de la
conversación porque creo que muchas
veces o desde que salió tiktok Facebook
o meta ha querido también ser un tiktok
por eso es que Instagram hoy tiene reels
por eso es que digamos que todos
apuntamos a generar contenido en video
porque termina siendo tan atractivo que
que Todos queremos ser eso sabes
Entonces ahí es donde la industria pues
y es donde hay que digamos que
aprovechar o decir Ok esto es importante
esto es relevante esto esto hay que
seguirlo
ahí está la discusión o el punto que
está debatiendo y los Mask y sus
abogados y es decirle a meta ustedes
están copiando Twitter y él asegura o la
carta que sus abogados le enviaron a
meta segura que contrataron a
funcionarios que Twitter había despedido
para crear un poco toda la información
que crea suites Qué tan cierto hay ahí
lo que pasa es que en Estados Unidos no
es como que la ley proteja precisamente
el tema de ideas sino que tiene que
haber una una forma de comprobación de
esto entonces hay que recordar la
historia de meta Y es que anteriormente
había sacado el lazo que era una
aplicación muy parecida a tiktok que no
funcionó también empezó a hacer el tema
de las historias apuntándole a ser
competencia de Snapchat entonces como
que también igual está jugando el mismo
juego lo ha hecho varias veces y es Y
hay que recordar que incluso Zuckerberg
quiso comprar Twitter dos veces entonces
claro no pude acceder a él Bueno montó
un modelo similar dentro de mi
ecosistema funciona Entonces esto esto
pasa a ser acá digamos que el debate y
la conversación es hasta qué punto sí se
puede mostrar que que sí efectivamente
utilizó exempleados de Twitter pero eso
ya es otra conversación y es una
conversación legal digamos en ese caso
pero no hay que negar el histórico de
meta Y es que durante mucho tiempo
también ha utilizado ideas de otros
creadores para implementarlos dentro de
su interfaz Entonces digamos que ahí la
conversación pasa a hacer eso qué tan
válido Javier es utilizar estas opciones
que son exitosas en el mercado y
replicarlas a su manera dentro de alguna
aplicación en meta ya como nos estaba
contando muy bien Karen ya lo hemos
visto con los reels que copian de tiktok
ahora Twitter y su ex que son muy
similares qué tan válido es esto o no
bueno pareciera que que es válido en el
sentido económico no le conviene
muchísimo más a a meta utilizar esta
estructura gigantesca que tiene vieron
que recién hablaba yo sobre el tema de
la competencia bueno es una empresa tan
grande con tantos datos acumulados de
distintos servicios que les
relativamente marginalmente fácil y
hasta inclusive poco costoso tomar una
característica de otra aplicación y
aplicar y utilizarla sobre su propia
infraestructura no esta infraestructura
enorme que ya tiene que también tiene
ejércitos de moderadores de contenidos
tiene muchísima Inteligencia artificial
que ha sido entrenada para ayudar en
todo lo que es recomendación de
contenidos también en fin tiene un
montón de infraestructura debajo para el
funcionamiento de una red que le da
estas ventajas competitivas hay
cuestiones que son más bien diría yo
como saltos cuánticos de la industria
hay cosas que más bien son muy difíciles
de probar como que son la idea original
de una persona el microblogging que por
ejemplo este este tipo de plataforma
como es tw sí es una idea que no es que
la inventó Twitter de hecho existe
también en alternativas de software
libre y de código abierto como estos
protocolos que yo mencionaba recién
federados en donde se ha ido
experimentando con esta idea de este
tipo de red social antes Entonces es
bastante difícil por ahí patentarla o
decir bueno Esto fue mi idea original Y
esta es la manera que está viendo
Igualmente también con la con la
estructura de diseño de usuario de
interfaces de
de usabilidad sí los colores ese tipo de
cosas son tan genéricas y se han hecho
tanto pasa que uno no las conoce uno
solo conoce los dominantes pero en este
en el ámbito de la tecnología Estas
ideas no son novedosas y por lo general
surgen de discusiones más abiertas más
transparentes en donde mucha gente
trabaja en ideas similares Entonces no
creo que el caso que intenta tener y lo
más contra meta vaya a prosperar en este
sentido hemos hablado de aspectos
tecnológicos aspectos políticos riesgos
legales y demás Pero quiero que tratemos
un tema que usted puntualizó al inicio
Karen y es la Salud Mental hay
diferentes estudios que prueban que
Instagram genera una inestabilidad
emocional en sus usuarios Usted cree que
corre este riesgo
Pues es que digamos que el tema aquí es
que las cuentas verificadas o lo que de
pronto para muchos era un filtro decir
Este es un perfil que me puede hablar
sobre algo especializado o tiene Digamos
como una autoridad sobre el tema se
trasladó automático cuando se crea la
cuenta entres entonces vemos Muchas
cuentas verificadas que realmente no es
que tengan una construcción de un
contenido sino solamente de fotografías
por ejemplo perfiles de modelos etcétera
claro cuando tú trasladas eso a una
conversación Ahora tienes que empezar a
evaluar eso o sea Hasta qué punto
digamos ese verificado sí va a ser un
una un criterio para poder decir esta
información que me está brindando x
personajes real o no O me puede afectar
o no Entonces digamos que ese es uno de
los puntos claves que que meta incluso
tiene que empezar a pensarlo así como en
su momento pensó en instagram el tema de
los filtros y el manejo del tiempo
cuando uno se la pasa mucho dentro de la
interfaz Entonces eso yo sí creo que
podría trasladar a algunas consecuencias
desde un punto crítico en el que el
usuario no sepa distinguir Entre qué
perfil si tiene una autoridad para
hablar por ejemplo de dietas que es una
una conversación que tenemos o de temas
de salud o de consejos para lo que sea x
o y que puede terminar asumiendo Incluso
como retos virales que hoy en día
conocemos que ponen en bastante peligro
a los niños que no tienen el criterio o
a personas adultas que incluso no no
diferencian entre lo que es cierto y lo
que puede tener una consecuencia Más
allá de lo que vi publicaba en una
plataforma Javier y su ex ya estaba
trabajando para poner algunas
restricciones y evitar estos riesgos en
la Salud Mental
a eso bueno habría que que averiguarlo
un poco mejor con la empresa yo creería
que sí creería que deben tener bastante
en cuenta todo lo que está sucediendo en
el mundo respecto a este tipo de
investigaciones esto que acaba de
mencionar Karen es muy importante de
hecho esto está casi siempre mucho más
enfocado en los adolescentes si este
tipo de estudios entonces me parece que
lo deben estar teniendo en cuenta hay
que recordar también que todo este
debate sobre la veracidad de lo que pasa
en las redes sociales es muy difícil de
de desgranar digamos por un lado estamos
exigiendo que en el lado de lo que
serían las verificaciones por ejemplo
podemos saber que una persona es quien
dice ser no Por lo general las
verificaciones son de identidad pero
como bien decía Karen no son de
contenido el tema del contenido Bueno
hay una responsabilidad por parte de las
empresas de siempre que detecten o que
alguien les diga si que hay contenido
malicioso que podría ser potencialmente
dañino y que de hecho está en contra de
las propias reglas que la empresa pone y
la propia empresa pone reglas las que
dice que ciertos contenidos por ejemplo
están prohibidos la forma en la que lo
empiecen a a aplicar a esa regla a
controlar lo que sucede cuidarse de que
no se recomienden contenidos que están
fuera de lo que de lo que se considera
viable dentro de las reglas es una de
las preguntas más importantes no sobre
cómo van a hacerlo para que Esas reglas
se cumplan y como hay nada y van a ir
adaptando sus reglas ahora al mismo
tiempo tampoco queremos que solamente
las plataformas sean las juezas de lo
que es lo necesario lo bueno lo sano en
las redes sociales porque son empresas
privadas que siempre van a poner su
lucro y su interés primero Sí por eso
las regulaciones y las conversaciones
sobre las regulaciones y qué detalles
tienen que tener para no ser
autoritarias son muy importantes y de
hecho son una de las grandes cosas que
se discuten hoy en día en el mundo y que
tan avanzadas tasa de discusión en
América Latina
la América Latina no está muy avanzada
hay proyectos de ley de regulación de
plataformas en distintos lugares con
distintos enfoques hay algunas que
tienen enfoque de desinformación otra
que tienen enfoques de Salud Mental
otras tienen enfoques de competencia de
datos personales bien Hay un montón de
cosas en Brasil por ejemplo hay una una
ley que se está discutiendo en este
momento que es bastante controvertida en
algunos de sus aspectos Sí pero que
creería yo uno de los intentos más
avanzados que hay más finos en estos
temas como decías un tema muy complejo
de terminar quién y cómo determina lo
decible en un espacio público Por más
que sea de una empresa privada
momentáneamente eso puede cambiar como
pasa con más no ahora pero determinar
quién puede hablar sobre Qué cosas
digamos es un debate muy complejo en una
democracia que justamente tiene a las
empresas como jugadoras pero también a
los gobiernos y a las leyes y al mismo
tiempo hay que hacer leyes que no sean
autoritarias porque sean abusado mucho
en el mundo leyes similares de este
estilo Karen con este panorama que hemos
discutido en la última media hora Cuál
es su conclusión de este duelo de
Titanes entre Twitter y traeds y
preguntarle si usted ya abrió Sí
evidentemente pues amante la tecnología
Apenas salió empecé a explorarlo empecé
a mirar cómo funcionaba y entender un
poco que hay detrás de de Cuál es el
objetivo que tiene esta plataforma Más
allá de abrir el debate y la
conversación y sin lugar a dudas yo sí
creo que la tecnología está para usarla
o sea el tema aquí es eduquémonos
aprendamos a usarla aprendamos a Pues
digamos a tener estos filtros aprendamos
a entender qué es lo que me está pasando
en el mundo porque pues no podemos
satanizarla final de cuentas eso nos ha
unido a lo largo de la historia y hoy en
día es muy fácil comunicarnos de un lado
a otro como para pues emplearla para
tener más brechas y para separarnos más
entonces creo que que por eso la
invitación es O sea la única forma de
entender que está pasando y de que el
usuario tenga el control es de verdad
teniendo el control probándolo Javier y
su conclusión y si ya tiene o no esta
aplicación
Sí sí yo soy también otro de Los amantes
de la tecnología que la tiene De hecho
quería bajarme la para ver bien cómo
funciona y empezar a leer todas estas
curiosidades no de los datos del
algoritmo de recomendación y todo eso
sí es importante como hago millas las
palabras también de Karen me parece muy
importante lo que dice creo que la
conclusión también es tratar de que las
tecnologías respeten un poco más los
derechos ser más atentos a las opciones
que hay y exigir que haya también
respuestas de las empresas y de los
gobiernos para que tengamos justamente
más debate público más opciones con
menos riesgos y menos sacrificio de
datos personales Y que todo sea por el
bienestar por supuesto de los usuarios
Karen rosso y Javier payro Gracias por
acompañarnos en el debate a ustedes
gracias por Buscar este programa y
elegirnos la producción estuvo a cargo
de Andrés doncel y la de los invitados
con Tania Herrera yo los dejo con más
información internacional en France 24
[Música]